got some combos that are really cool
especially with the charged vertical
sword that we also saw from him but a
number one that dad charged six aid
really amazing move uphill tough yeah a
link is gonna have to play a Ronda you
consistently during dispatch of that
charge six a is kind of what got him
into top eight right like a lot of the
time it was either somebody wasn't ready
for the second to happen or or he used
it as a really strong with punish like
you were talking about you know and so I
definitely think that that's going to be
a big established established move for
for the matchup and so one of the things
I we were asking link or is like how do
you feel about Hilda and he was like I
really don't know anything about this
character right I mean I know very
little also this is definitely new and
what's tough about what's all about link
is that he's been playing more and more
girly not that siegfried is not also
amazing right uh-huh and killed is as we
said are really amazing well-rounded
character but his hyper character that
thrives on knowledge suppose the more
that you know about a particular matchup
and the more opportunity you have to
step their game and get them to whip
bunch of things like this the better
that girl becomes right but when you
kind of don't really know what's going
on and you're just situation becoming
random and you're flailing away a little
bit
Jerald IMO is it's not very powerful in
that situation you think said so I think
that will make things tough for okay
yeah no and I mean also he's he's also
had the story like history with
Siegfried right so so let's get
sometimes it becomes like a
comfortability thing well you know what
would Siegfried it's almost like I'm not
saying that this will influence think in
any way but with Siegfried it's almost
like you could kind of say okay I'm
gonna go on a soil charge and pace hold
and go over my base hold low and you can
ham it up a little bit more maybe but
then what would Garrett I don't think
that too many mistakes will be allowed
well you were earlier talking about
hooker what was kind of like an all
arounder right yeah he's like
well-rounded but so I'm surprised to
hear that that you think that it would
be harder for him to fight somebody that
has a that you have little knowledge of
since that's the thing right with war
under characters just my opinion right
okay you're playing a war on the
character right like let's say you're
the Riu guy right okay the more you know
about the matchup the easier it is to be
Ryu you know when it's okay to throw
your fireballs and when it's okay to do
certain things right okay well girl I
see any type of thing right like this is
not a matchup necessarily where you can
just be like okay haha I have meter I'm
gonna
Phoebe now I don't I don't think that
that's gonna work too well against Josh
in fact I think that Josh it will hurt
McCoys terribly for going to that basic
strategy right so he could go to grow
which apparently he may have I think
this is a character I mean I think is a
button check though but we're gonna find
out I kind of like this more to be
honest grow was the card so he had been
playing a lot last year it's not like
it's not like he didn't have this
character in the pocket or any thought I
haven't mentioned that I've got almost
kind of forgotten about but I kind of
like this little [ __ ] I just I just
didn't expect it you know what I mean
grow so grow didn't get any nerves or
anything like that this patch right he
kind of got a little bit of buffs but
the thing is he didn't really get
anything that helped him in the issues
that he had so he's kind of he kind of
remained stagnant but if he feels the
matchup is better I I see no reason as
to why he wouldn't want to do it uh-uh
shaking hands I guess we're gonna find
out right now in just a moment will he
lock there it is Siegfried okay it's
like I said it's not impossible for him
to have gone to the ground no of course
not or even Carol Gerald would have also
been a fine choice from him of course
one of the cactus most won't know for I
like this pick the most out of the
roster that we know him to play and
we'll see how joshing will answer again
it's going to come down a lot to his
knowledge of this character so I know a
second ago I did mention that he can
know much about this character but one
thing that did happen is he played with
some Hilda's last night so here he has a
little bit more knowledge than he did
prior but there we go round star oh he
was back to her really unfortunate right
there he didn't get the turn around
well out of reach for that gas Hilda has
a lot of strong horizontals that's the
charge 6a right there oh yeah when
you're in when you're in dark legacy fat
people that'll feel it over and over
again it will never stop and make the
city's getting full attack comes out oh
yeah oh we got about the legacy he came
back see that's the explosive power seat
free that's what he can do absolutely
he's always been able to do that too
that's been one of his strongest suits
in this version yeah she got you that
and I just because sikri is a little bit
weaker does not necessarily mean that
the best secretes are not gonna show you
loud Matt Josh it is such fun
so consist I you know I wonder if that's
actually nutty or if that's just one of
her best possible options that happens
because it looks so incredible that
buggy that tech crotch was got my by the
way it's whoa unfortunately I think what
he recognized was they didn't have the
frame to go for the lethal hit there so
you an opt-in to get frame advantage in
standard right back at you with that
slide be
whoa unsure of how ways go with that
guarantee Oh Gigi answer another
finishing it off so that's very close to
the wall you get that huh oh just the
smears down the commode counter change
so I think I was a texture okay I see
got the Stein bar fast pace Oh
3p role with the latex yes oh no GI
again I work so well I I guess he's
identified a button rhythm that that
Josh going for because I mean hey he's
been hitting it pretty much until he sat
down way too into face hold with a
budget that's one of the nice parts
about Basil's this whole truck comes out
you recognizes that the 6a hat it has
the ability to be charged at this point
right back at you and for wolf Crone
right now who's crazier oh I am p6 okay
nice Johnson recognize that there was a
fighter there even Oh big damage
TechShop time didn't know
whoa that was super good right so he
delayed it long enough right because it
looked like Josh and tried to tack
crushed under it but because he delayed
it long enough is with the hitbox ended
up standing into it I think he just
tried to witbier okay I see something we
found that threw me right now all my
face says that definitely could have
idea the idea there a suggestion bet
that was a tough first game that was
actually close by but was a box there
reviewer running at he does you know
sometimes when you don't necessarily
know that match oh it's not the best
thing to do is is don't wanna play yeah
just floor it man those best you can go
just like that right there
Oh Hilda's on her home turf now three
eight four right there [ __ ] I'm
stepping no time so he's 100 scary yeah
whoa again that was also scary man that
six is great okay so I do think you
truly identified with the bass honk nice
seat though big boy Dan full extension
time for a Czech tribe he got it ok not
this time if you buddy get up
immediately after the tech trap you know
I you know sometimes you're trying to
conditioner gently not the full crouch
being able to finish it off right there
you know when you have the opponents
scared enough it seems to go for those
win fix ups because they're not really
trying to try to go for the middle again
joshan's defense remaining stalwart so
charges come in I need some space my
friend take it all my goodness when he
tried to stop long enough to follow up
or deny he comes our can you choose
whether or not to do the follow I have
no idea but I notice everybody's been
getting hit by it when it's so good I
know
just trying to keep the joshan and not
the why he's one more round to take it
this is a loser's bracket Joshua would
be eliminated at seventh place jumping
low gets nothing that was a great block
but unfortunately it wasn't negative
enough for him to punish Rio he's
catching all the steps right now Josh a
lot of beer available he might so charge
is a credible call right there
not only did Eri
but then going for the guard impact
afterwards I saw just a small tint of
red and I was like what is that oh my
god ready go yeah I mean that's
guaranteed off that yeah so you got the
lethal hit ended up taking the round
right there incredible read or read from
Lynn Corey's that was a mail for him so
that will seal him and he'll continue on
the tournament
unfortunately uh no more he'll do it
guys but should we love to see wow she's
amazing field of this tournament she
made top eight Josh made top eight which
means it's gonna Rob some nice points
for the world